I'm going to teach you some things about
factorization now you know that
factorization but already you've been
doing it ever since you really learned
about algebra actually which is year
seven before that was a lot of
interesting factorization is one side of
the two-sided coin of the two basic
skills you learned in algebra what's the
opposite of factorizing it's expanding
play so in fact I think you'll find the
actual chatter the chalica is called
expanding and saturating the factor ID
is really where the action is at
expanding is something we can do
somewhat Bible sleep so for example
taught me a few I'm just going to put
this away from Roman come back to this
you can take any little set of things
with rabbit in it like this okay so if I
gave you this we would all know how to
expand this might take us a bit of time
to get out beautiful not so help me up
both of these are called binomials can
anyone guess why they're both called a
binomial of myoga any takers is tutos
okay you can see that it's really it's
really because they've been doing
products and factors how do I expand
this pair of my Robles what do I do
don't give me the input give me the
information how any takers
yeah it doesn't I can do do with your
fingers what are you okay so this by the
way this process that this program has a
name such as the do not the name of this
is called what you're doing is you're
taking this five right by the way
there's an operation that's applied in
the middle between its package what is
it multiplication but mathematicians
famously lazy so we will write it
whistles we possibly can this is five
times what you're doing is you're
distributing that five times across both
of these terms so we call this order
okay so now let's actually do the
distributive I'll do that thing you were
doing which is prettiest okay what are
you going to get out when you do the
husband Hey okay yeah okay so now you've
started to distribute the second thing
which is the a times okay so I think I
heard a squared
okay very good once you've done this you
can see you're not drugged cuz what else
can you do there
all right so you can click like to I
said some of you say the word simplify
textbooks and questions and
mathematicians use the word simplify all
the time I'm going to consciously avoid
it because simplify is a very broad term
it can mean almost anything in fact
sometimes I mean you're taking we
collect like terms how do you collect
end of it or you can get very everything
else including you so these going to be
collected we call that rightly
simplification that sometimes
simplification is not going in this
direction in sometimes going in addition
as you'll learn a bit later on so I'm
going to avert avoid the word simplified
because it has such a broad meaning I
prefer to say expand factorize it
collect like terms tell me what kind of
simplification you're actually doing so
rewind them I said after I did expanding
are two sides of the same coin right
they reverse a process to each other the
expanding is pretty simple though like
you ironically I you don't have to think
very much to do this expansion which is
why you learn how to do this quite
simply in year 7
but factorizing this that took a bit
more time he United met this new tender
than doing this very recently
factorizing is a harder skill and that's
why it's so important I had this two
truck
I suspect driving madam factorizing my
battery factorizing is about revealing
structure factorizing is about revealing
structure when you understand the
structure of something you understand
the theme set up the periodic table
right you guys have all encountered the
periodic table before what I call it the
periodic table why is that so yet
okay so periodic so the data dictionary
says kind of period okay so what does
that mean like what does it mean for
something to have to why did he knows
was it remember I'll become the person
who makes it so crazy
hello earth ah
in organizing year the differently
we're going to the end of the okay she
cast at the pewter table is arranged in
columns Emperor's acquaint to the
properties that they have right now you
mentioned things like balance II what's
the only missions are number of orbitals
so many electrons ago you will enter
okay now what's interesting is that
those properties emerge when you
understand how many what moves you from
one period now that's the next what
changes failure do they gave the proton
wrestler to that little mercy you so
every time you gain a proton you change
properties but eventually if you add a
set number protons you well back to a
similar kind of property that you've
seen before in other words it's periodic
it repeats right now understanding the
structure of what's going on inside the
nucleus tells you everything about an
atom just quite astonishing really so if
you can understand the structure of
something you gain insight into it it's
not just don't read an assortment of 100
and 318 objects there's actually a
patent in structure which is why when
you came in I asked you to baptize some
numbers way okay now come back I will
give you all different numbers and I
think I started with 36 and I got up to
I don't know I'm some really family by
the time I went around okay the thing I
asked you to do with this I asked you to
take the number and then worked out in
this you hopefully remember this from
you 7,000 is prime factorizations this
is my summary of the number okay this is
me looking and saying what is this not
available how many neutrons and protons
and electrons are worth whizzing around
inside this because if I understand that
I can gain deeper insight into the
number or into the outer
try and prove to you okay so what I want
you to do now when your pair of numbers
you've already found it like I have
I want you to do something else there I
asked for the prime factorization the
prime factorization now I'd like you to
do for your number is I want you to list
all of the factors full stop all of the
factors of your number there might be
quite a few so for instance 24 we can
all do this together let's do 24 1 is a
factor of every natural number okay you
can already see some of the numbers that
are on here are included I've got 2 3 &
4 & 6 they're all included one of the
factors am I missing that are not on the
board but are factors of 24 make what's
after that 12 did I catch a ball okay
sorry I must conserve McArdle's moment
so alright that that is the list of
factors of 24 can you go ahead and with
all those factors make sure you don't
miss any but the two numbers I've given
you if you didn't get numbers then raise
your hand and I'll give you some